first of all I haven't spoken to you
since you won a Golden Glove very well
deserved by the way you really became a
different person in this movie you
deserve this Golden Globe and I'm just
what was it like when you were up on
stage getting that I wouldn't think
you've won so many awards that you would
get nervous at this bow I'd every time I
get terrified and also I've been there
before and I've not won a Golden Globe
before so I was fully prepared to not
win so and then they said my name was
almost like I turned to my friend
Stephen as I did I did because I heard
my name I wanted to get you know just
verification that you know what's go on
yeah you don't want to go up if they
didn't call you you know from Carol
Burnett Show
oh-o-oh Tim Conger hardly did that Tim
Conway is a genius and always was a
genius and every year at the Emmys where
Whitney would announce his category he
would lose and he would get up and go up
anyway it was fantastic one of the
greatest comedy minds ever yeah so
anyway I went up there and I was
grateful because Oprah literally was
sitting right right there right in the
front at the front table so anyone
giving an acceptance speech had you it
was basically you could not see Oprah
and I was so grateful by the time I had
won she had gone back to prepare for her
award she was getting so she was not
there and I felt it was it kind of maybe
I was because I was nervous it's very
distracting I know I did an award show
once and she was sitting right up front
yeah and she has such a presence that
you are conscious the whole time that
Oprah is watching you yeah and that if
she's displeased she can have you
removed just a wave of and you know you
were I saw this picture of you on the
carpet at the Golden Globes looks like
you're chugging oh yeah you're chugging
champagne all right I had a lot of
comments about that and I must clarify
because that they put these long flutes
on there and so I wanted to go slowly
because I thought it's gonna be like a
slushy thing you know when it finally
comes down the tube was just gonna go
careening into my face so I was so it
looked like I was drinking for quite a
long time when I was just slowly
you see when is it when is it gonna come
out it's not coming out and then finally
you know yeah well it explain why you
had nine bottles that's the part that no
one can understand BRE your story your
story it goes a little thin when you are
yeah
you